nosotros digamos no sé la gente moderna
damos por hecho la existencia de las
células y la idea de que todo ser
viviente está hecho de células y que por
ejemplo nosotros los seres humanos que
somos seres vivientes estamos hechos de
muchísimas células es más se estima que
en un cuerpo humano hay aproximadamente
unos 37 billones 37 billones de células
hay aproximadamente 37 billones de
células eso es un número muy grande
verdad pero si regresamos digamos el
tiempo no se digamos unos 400 años si
nos vamos a los años 1600 esto no era
muy obvio y eso se debe a que la gente
no tenía las herramientas para hacer
observaciones directas de las células no
sabían que existían es más no sabían que
existían organismos unicelulares pero
todo eso comenzó a cambiar con robert
hooke ok
hooke quien por cierto fue de las
primeras personas en sacarle provecho al
microscopio
e hizo uno muy primitivo y de hecho por
ejemplo aquí tenemos una imagen de este
microscopio muy primitivo esto que
tenemos del lado derecho es es un lente
verdad y digamos comparado con el
microscopio moderno pues claramente es
muy primitivo verdad por ejemplo aquí
tenemos una flama cuya luz fuck lograba
dirigir para reflejar las sobre lo que
estuviera observando y digamos esto en
realidad está data del año mil 665 esto
es del año mil 665 en donde publica este
texto digamos llamado micrografía o no
sé si lo estoy pronunciando bien digamos
micrografía y digamos que en este texto
lo que hace es dibujar muchas de sus
observaciones utilizando su microscopio
que había diseñado verdad y de hecho
tiene unos dibujos fascinantes digamos
ahora era todo un artista verdad de
hecho tiene dibujos de moscas de pulgas
y en particular tiene un dibujo
de corcho verdad digamos esta es la
imagen del corcho en donde podemos
observar estas unidades verdad estas
especies de cuadrados verdad que tiene
el corcho verdad que estoy incluso aquí
remarcando y
estas unidades básicas del corcho que
observo les llamo células y en realidad
el término célula era porque le
recordaba a digamos a las las
habitaciones digamos donde permanecían
los monjes cristianos ok entonces a este
tipo de cosas a estas a estas
observaciones más bien les llamo células
estas son células y desafortunadamente
no se tiene ningún retrato de robert
hooke de hecho de hecho se cree que
newton quemó el único cuadro de robert
hulk que existía pero bueno esa es otra
historia que contaremos quizás en otra
ocasión verdad y aunque aunque robert
hooke acuñó el término de célula en
realidad sólo observó tejido muerto
verdad sólo vio digamos el remanente de
la pared celular en estos cuadraditos
del corcho ok sólo vio el remanente de
la pared celular y él no estableció que
fuera por ejemplo que las células fueran
unidad básica ni que se reproducen ni
que toda célula proviene de otra célula
en realidad esto se fue desarrollando a
lo largo
es más unos años más adelante podemos
distinguir al famoso anthony band living
juego o alguna pronunciación similar no
no sé exactamente cómo se pronuncia y le
dijo que era holandés y de hecho fue
inspirado en el trabajo de hook verdad
de hecho lo que él trató de desarrollar
fueron mejores lentes y para poder hacer
mejores microscopios y de hecho el
living fue capaz de observar células
vivas en particular él pudo distinguir
digamos espermatozoides vivos
espermatozoides
y pudo ver espermatozoides y no sólo
pudo observar espermatozoides también
pudo observar lo que ahora conocemos
como protistas verdad son un tipo
especial de organismos son organismos
eucariontes unicelulares pero living coc
los llamo ánima q los animales
muy bien que podríamos pensar que lo
llamo así verdad que son como como
animales diminutos cierto así que en
realidad todo esto no es la teoría
no se formó ahí la teoría celular
moderna sino fue más o menos 150 años
después digamos a inicios del siglo 19
digamos si nos vamos a los años 1830
podemos distinguir
matías y slide en la ciudad
swan ok digamos ellos iniciaron los
fundamentos de la teoría celular moderna
verdad que que tenía algunos puntos muy
particulares así que ellos iniciaron lo
que ahora conocemos como la teoría
celular iniciaron algunos fundamentos de
la teoría celular y ellos decían
principalmente dos cosas la primera de
ellas es que toda la vida toda la vida
está compuesto ésta está compuesta por
células
la vida está
compuesta
células esa era digamos el primer
postulado que establecía la teoría
celular y el segundo de ellos el segundo
postulado digamos decía
el segundo postulado de la teoría
celular decía o dice que la célula es la
unidad básica ok es la unidad básica de
la vida
básica de la vida
vida
y esta digamos no es la teoría celular
completa verdad de hecho muchas personas
ya sabían que las células podían venir o
provenir de otras células pero en
realidad era una pregunta abierta si las
células podían ser creadas a partir de
sustancias y condiciones adecuadas de
hecho no fue sino hasta mediados del
siglo 19 o hasta mediados del siglo 19
que tuvimos el tercer punto de la teoría
celular el tercer punto de la teoría
celular es muy interesante y dice que
todas las células todas las células
provienen de otras células
de otras
y digamos el la persona que desarrolló
digamos este tercer punto fue robert
rímac ok y digamos a veces se le da
también crédito a rudolf virchow o
alguna pronunciación así pero en
realidad resulta que virtió plagio el
trabajo del rímac así que en realidad
digamos la persona indicada para para
darle el crédito de este tercer punto
debería ser robert ryman muy bien pero
bueno en realidad recordemos no fue la
primera persona en observar que algunas
células provienen de otras células en
realidad lo que él dijo es que es
digamos es una cuestión fundamental y
dijo que de que todas las células
provienen de otras células es decir dice
de dónde provienen todas las células
verdad es decir no surgen de manera
espontánea muy bien
ahora bien incluso hoy en día la gente
se pregunta algo muy natural verdad
debió existir una primera célula o un
conjunto inicial de proto células y la
gente no está 100% segura pero cuando
volteamos atrás al proceso a observar el
proceso evolutivo de la vida en la
tierra se estima que las células
surgieron hace aproximadamente 3.5 mil
millones de años y no están 100% seguros
pero hay algunas teorías por ejemplo
tenemos ya hechos vídeos de fosfolípidos
en khan academy y resulta que estos
forman de manera natural digamos
los fosfolípidos estos forman de manera
natural alguna lo que conocemos como be
capas muy bien estos forman vi capas y
de hecho pueden formar membranas
esféricas pueden formar membranas
esféricas verdad y esto lo hacen de
manera espontánea que estas membranas
esféricas están hechas de vic capas y se
forman espontáneamente también hay
teorías digamos de que la maquinaria que
posee la información de la célula quizás
su ancestro era una molécula digamos
era una molécula auto replicante de la
rn muy bien puede ser una molécula auto
replicante de adn o quizás otro tipo de
molécula auto replicante muy bien y
bueno la importancia es que quizás esta
proteína auto replicante verdad que
parezca las de tiempo muy largos fueron
después capaces de replicarse de tener
una maquinaria más sofisticada y digamos
los que se parecían ahora más a las
células modernas quizás pudieron tener
un mejor aprovechamiento de la energía o
de los recursos del ambiente y que
eventualmente llegaron a ser las células
modernas y esta es una pregunta
fascinante y que de hecho todavía es un
área completa de investigación